1936 and France is having an election so
French politics at this point can
largely be described as a dumpster fire
they were divisive violent and ruling
was extremely difficult this election
was won by a left-wing coalition called
the Popular Front with a man called Leon
Blum taking over as Prime Minister
sidenote France did have a president at
this point but he wasn't important
anyway with the elections behind them in
a clear mandate you'd think that
governing France would be less difficult
but fun fact no the government needed to
sort out the economy because Great
Depression which was made more difficult
in large scale strikes broke out across
the country these were settled with what
were called the Matignon agreements
which saw the introduction of a 40-hour
workweek as well as better paying
conditions blooms government also had to
deal with the right-wing paramilitary
league they're quite a few the cross a
file at by Army veteran Francois della
Roque the government came up with a
subtle way of doing this
they banned them this didn't stop
conservatives in France from fearing the
worst though in fact many believed that
the victory of the Popular Front with
its communist support heralded the
coming of a communist revolution in
France with the support of the USSR
these fears were misplaced though in the
Popular Front would suffer from the same
instability in infighting that the
previous coalition's had dealt with Blum
resigned in 1937 and was replaced by
Camilla Chantal who frankly didn't do
much
his government collapsed in early 1938
and thus Blum returned for less than a
month Blum was replaced by Edouard
Daladier in April until a da's
government was focused not on france's
internal problems but instead upon
germany which are recently annexed
Austria which it wasn't supposed to do
this was followed up by Germany's leader
a certain Adolf Hitler from demanding
this area the Sudetenland from france's
staunch ally czechoslovakia this
resulted in a Munich conference whereby
France and Britain agreed that Germany
would be allowed to annex the
Sudetenland Czechoslovakia itself wasn't
invited to this meeting because they'd
only do things like disagree it should
be noted the very few in France were
willing to tolerate the idea of war at
this point both sides of the political
spectrum were filled with pacifists who
believed that the cost of war as
demonstrated by the devastation of the
First World War were never worth it
France was very proud of the Munich
Agreement and saw it as a great victory
in Tula da's popularity soared until
Hitler conquered the rest of
Czechoslovakia that is Frances
appeasement of Hitler's territorial
ambitions could only go so far Germany
invaded Poland on September the 1st 1939
into
later France declared war on Germany
alongside Britain what followed was not
an intense push into Germany but what
the French called the troll de Guerre or
as is known in English the phoney war
this was basically when neither side did
much except clash at sea because the
French did not wish to push into Germany
in Germany could not push into France
the reason for this was the extremely
potent line of fortifications called the
Maginot Line this wasn't designed to be
impenetrable but was supposed to force
Germany to go around through Luxembourg
and Belgium because better to fight a
war there than at home till a ta now saw
the Communist Party is a potential
threat because the USSR had signed a
non-aggression pact with the Third Reich
the molotov-ribbentrop pact this led to
many communists being arrested and
forced into exile there was still a
sizable movement of people who wanted
peace it's just too early on patriotism
ran high this lasted until
franco-british relations hit a few snags
this was because the British botched the
defense of Norway which soon fell to the
Germans the failures here led to de la
da being ousted and replaced by a man
called Paul Reynaud the phoney war came
to an end in May of 1940 when Germany as
the Maginot Line dictated push through
Belgium to advance into France they also
took the Netherlands because why not
long story short the German army pushed
their tanks through a heavily forested
area which wasn't accounted for they
then came into contact with some poorly
trained French recruits broke through
and then pushed a wedge between the
French forces to the south and the
franco-british forces to the north the
British retreated to Dunkirk where they
then bravely ran away as French troops
fought to cover their retreat it was
extremely brutal and bloody fighting the
British now believed that France was
doomed to fallen so refused to commit
resources to a defense which deeply
strained the alliance France began to
collapse at this point which was
hastened by Italy joining the war
against them - on the 14th of June Paris
was captured and reynor after refusing
to hold peace talks resigned on the 16th
this was after people in both the French
and British governments proposed a
radical plan to keep France fighting the
franco-british Union this was where both
nations would be merged into one under a
single government and military command
was trained on Churchill with strong
supporters of the move it was rejected
by other French ministers because too
many of them they were simply being
asked to choose between domination by
the Germans or by the British after
Reyna was gone it was his deputy in one
of the main proponents of an armistice
who took over for him a certain Philippe
Petain on the 22nd of June at Compiegne
the same place Germany signed its
armistice at the end of World War 1
France agree to peace on German
these terms these word that one France
would be divided into two zones and
occupied zone in the north which the
French would pay for in a free zone in
the south to the French fleet would stay
in their home ports but the Germans
would leave them alone three the French
army was limited to one hundred thousand
men and for all French prisoners would
remain in captivity until Britain made
peace Britain did not believe that
condition number two would be honored
and so sent an automaton to the French
and over your ships docked in North
Africa over to us or else the French
said no because they'd agreed not to in
the armistice and so the Royal Navy
attacked killing over a thousand French
sailors and crippling the fleet there to
put it mildly the French government was
furious this new French government was
based at the town of Vichy and pétain
sought to secure his new government he
saw a greater powers for his position so
he could push through far-reaching
reforms Petain believed that France had
suffered a catastrophic defeat because
its people had become weak many in
France a green and Petain was voted
massive emergency powers to basically
rewrite the French Constitution however
he wished he did three things he
abolished the presidency he made himself
head of the French state with near
absolute legal powers and he dismissed
Parliament the new regime officially
called the French state but better known
as Vichy France operated in tandem with
the Germans French volunteers served
with the German army the Vichy regime
conducted air raids against her alter
many Frenchmen went to work in German
industry many of those who fought with
the Germans were simply stringent
anti-communist and even held the motto
better Hitler than Blum
although please be aware that many of
those who served in the factories did
this simply out of desperation and
others did it because they were forced
to the third French Republic was over at
least officially that is there were
those both inside and outside of France
who had refused to accept the Armistice
and wanted to continue the fight against
Germany inside of France the French
Resistance was formed and operated in
both occupied and Vichy France they
undertook sabotage espionage and
assassinations to weaken German and
Vichy forces the French Resistance
wasn't simply one group of people it's
the collective name for various groups
early on resistance was mounted by
conservative and Catholic groups but
after the German invasion of the USSR in
1941 Stalin authorized communist groups
to resist - outside of France Britain in
the remnants of the French military
which had fled attempted to group these
resistance fighters under the umbrella
of the French forces of the Interior
which was to be led by a certain Charles
de Gaulle however the Communists weren't
interested in working with the
conservative to güell
many Frenchmen saw him as nothing more
than a British puppet and a traitor this
viewpoint changed as the war turned
against Germany whose advance into the
Soviet Union had stalled to make matters
worse the US had joined the war and
along with the rest of the Allies in the
Free French were advancing across North
Africa as the Vichy and German forces
were pushed back to Gaul began to gain
legitimacy and many French soldiers
deserted to him and turned against the
Vichy government so de Gaulle had a
difficult relationship with the British
and the Americans he was largely left
out of decision-making not treated as an
equal and Roosevelt was also willing to
work with Vichy France whom he saw as
more legitimate and potentially more
useful that was until November 1942 when
the Germans decided to put an end to
Vichy France and along with the Italians
invaded in order to seize the French
fleet Vichy France his last act was to
scuttle most of the fleet at Toulon as
French sailors held off the German
soldiers attempting to seize them anyway
the war continued to move in the Allies
favor by 1944 the Allies decided to
finally invade France
On June the 6th 1944 better known as
d-day the Allies landed their forces in
Normandy and gained a foothold in August
the Allies mostly American and Free
French forces landed in southern France
and pushed to here so de Gaulle would
achieve his dream of liberating Paris on
the 25th of August 1944 this was done
with very little fighting in the city
itself with a general Leclerc did engage
in heavy fighting south of Paris a
provisional government were set up with
de Gaulle as its head and whilst France
most certainly aided with the continued
advance into Germany for many notably
those in the resistance the war was over
pertain incidentally was taken to
Germany and later returned to France
where he was arrested after Germany's
capitulation in 1945 France was given
zones of occupation in Germany in
Austria but be aware this was not a sure
thing
President Roosevelt and later President
Truman believed that since many
Frenchmen had fought alongside the
Germans that they would be treated as a
conquered nation Britain was against
this and in the end the Americans
acquiesced in France was to be treated
as a victorious power in case you're
wondering Britain wasn't doing this to
be nice it simply meant that a rearmed
France would be the primary military
defender of Western Europe which was not
a position that the Brits wanted with
the war over de Gaulle now had the
difficult job of rebuilding the French
government in the country the French
state and appertain was gone and so de
Gaulle sought to create the fourth
French Republic which wouldn't suffer
from the weaknesses of the third spoiler
alert it did dugu reinstated the
previously elected officials and
on trial who was found guilty and given
life in prison by 1946 a new
constitution had been approved an
election saw the communist party win the
most seats but it was Leon Blum who
returned as Prime Minister France over
the next few years received immense sums
of money from the USA in the Marshall
Plan to rebuild and join the Cold War
against the USSR despite the popularity
of the Communist Party there so France
was devastated by the second world war
one of the things Charles DeGaulle was
hoping to do was to rebuild French
prestige in Europe France joined the UN
Security Council as a permanent member
rebuilt its military and sought to find
its new role in the world ultimately
world war two's legacy in France is very
complicated France still struggles with
determining whether or not Vichy France
was legitimate whether or not surrender
was better than fighting to the bitter
end and to what extent the liberation of
France was a French one I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching and a special thanks to Thomas
guest Strich Adam Harvey Winston Cawood
and James businet if you'd like to know
more about France during the Second
World War there are some book
recommendations in the description below
you